hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday March 11th 2019 what's going on
how are ya
Oh how you doing I'm at a great move
despite the fact that I missed that
[ __ ] the first MotoGP race of the of
the year I found out DIRECTV
isn't doesn't have it on [ __ ]
television anymore out here which was
very disappointing to me you know I
couldn't find it I was scampering I woke
up in a sweat go wait a minute wait does
f1 start today right freaking out OCD
[ __ ] 20 goddamn races god forbid you
missed one so I look up f1 that doesn't
start till next week down in Australia
okay I already have that recorded that's
easy because that got picked up by ESPN
so I'm like alright where the [ __ ] the
MotoGP I have DIRECTV alright I'm not
trying to talk down to all you people
that's right I can still afford to pay
for cable that's how [ __ ] hard I am
out here in these streets all you
[ __ ] cord cutters huh
just backing yourself into a [ __ ]
entertainment corner just sitting there
on with your apps and your little
Netflix [ __ ] subscription that's your
world huh what are you gonna do watch
every episode of narcosis and then some
stupid documentary to try and press your
friends you what you need you need those
700 [ __ ] channels that they have 300
of which are radio stations
what do you walk it away from
Millennials what are you afraid of
they're all proud of it too
because when I couldn't find it on
Direct TV I went on to the Twitter and
very nicely dare I say eloquently I just
put out to the Twittersphere
I said hey does anybody know what
channel the MotoGP is on on Direct TV
and the [ __ ] come out of the woodwork
Jesus Christ you would have thought I'd
put a [ __ ] piece of cheese down in a
bun all the [ __ ] little rats that
came running out right so rats even eat
cheese don't they kind of eat anything
you don't even like if you just put like
a severed finger in a mousetrap wouldn't
a [ __ ] rat eventually come up and try
and eat the [ __ ] thing I mean I don't
give a [ __ ] right there like that
relative that always shows up to the
event never brings anything and just
hovers right hovers around the [ __ ]
table doesn't use that [ __ ] spoon you
know to scoop it is reach it in with
this [ __ ] mitts that's what rats are
all right that's a rat and so she Runkle
anyways plowing ahead so I put it out
there nicely okay I like to feel like
you know being a man in my 50s now that
I am I am refined I am a man of the
world all right
I Drive a four-door sedan I still pay
for cable okay so I'm like this close to
buying a pair of loafers you understand
like that that is like how established I
am as an adult so I put it out there
nicely does anybody know what channel
the MotoGP race is on on DIRECTV
oh these [ __ ] [ __ ] come out of the
woodwork I first of all you channel 69
huh you got it are you gonna try that
uh-huh right then they start doing this
one burst then they start speaking in
Twitter speak I didn't know that DirecTV
was still a thing oh wow man you're like
so cool the way you the way you get your
entertainment Jesus Christ you wouldn't
see what I thought I showed up with a
[ __ ] I don't know the wrong pair of
sneakers on it when I was like in fifth
grade the fact that I actually suggested
I still I had no idea that was so much
shame and still haven't DirecTV I pay
like 200 bucks a month for cable that's
why to God
what do you think I went from one
[ __ ] podcast a week to to I got to
pay for my DirecTV I do you know
somebody told me one time he goes dude
you're paying way too much money just
can't me come over there and I'll yell
I'll cut it in half because all these
[ __ ] people Accord cutting and shitty
can you know I have all the sports
packages oh yeah I'm talking [ __ ] here
people okay I pay for DirecTV I have all
four sports packages all right and I
miss most the games okay you want to
talk about taking hundreds of just
throwing them into a fire a lightness
cigars that's how I'm rolling anyway so
it turns out that DirecTV no longer
carries MotoGP which in my world is the
best [ __ ] racing out there as far as
if you want to see excitement if you
want passing okay you [ __ ] NASCAR
guys down there huh with your [ __ ]
still that also doubles as the smoker
during the tailgate you want to get
drunk you stand on this side if you want
some Buffalo but you get on that side
right you guys want to see [ __ ]
excitement if you want to see passing in
that type of [ __ ] you want to see if you
want to see a wreck watch a [ __ ] guy
high side on a motorcycle going like
[ __ ] 200 miles an hour like once
every three races this just something
that would make Evel Knievel be like
Jesus [ __ ] Crouch that guy's still
alive at which point you say it's called
an air bag Evel you know they watched
your little jump there at [ __ ]
Caesars who might say Evel Knievel would
laugh at that [ __ ] there little
light bikes and their [ __ ] air bags
you know he went out there wearing a
[ __ ] pair of leather underoos and got
on a [ __ ] chopper you can [ __ ] it by
down at the local store like way more
than my goddamn head anyway you want to
watch this MotoGP so I [ __ ] in ended
up going online
everybody's like why don't you watch it
on reddit for free or whatever so I
didn't I go to MotoGP their website I
sign up for this season one hundred and
thirty nine bucks right more money more
money just [ __ ] just flying out the
window right so
I signed up for it and then I'm such an
old guy I couldn't figure out where to
watch it and I finally figured it out
after the race was over you got to click
on there's like four lines on the side
and one of them says live and when you
click on that that's the [ __ ] race
and by the time I figured that out
you know it's counting down like [ __ ]
you know 9000 hours until the next
goddamn race so I missed it
and like all MotoGP races that it
sounded like it was exciting as hell and
it came right down to the end and Davitt
CEO so beat my mom like he did last year
by like the length of his bike and I
don't know I'm hoping if anybody you
know watches it on MotoGP site if they
replay it I can't even find a [ __ ]
highlight of it but anyways so all you
rednecks down there who like your stock
car racing just it's 20-something laps
it'll go by in two seconds and I know
it's a bunch of foreigners out there on
their little moto scooters I ain't
nobody named Cale or Harry or Dale you
know there's a mark that's kind of a you
know
Andres divisio so Jorge Lorenzo close
the border
I'd like to build a wall around that
[ __ ] racetracks what the [ __ ] I'd
like to do jump over that [ __ ]
so anyways I I might seem a little like
my energy is a little higher a little
more giddy it's because I ain't doing
[ __ ] I got a special in the can man and
I'm just I haven't done stand-up since I
said good night on the second show and
tonight I'm actually going down to the
to the comedy store that it's closed to
the public it's just for comics only and
it's the memorial for Brody Stephens
which i think is going to be I think
it's gonna be great
it's gonna be sad but I really think
it's like he's such an uplifting guy and
it was so so much to learn from him that
I am really looking forward to going
down there and celebrating that guy's
life
the work that he that he did down at the
Comedy Store one of the legends one of
the legends there's a place out front
where they put all the all the names
that the people that really built that
place and kept it going I hope they move
his name up there that's what I'm going
to suggest so anyway yeah all I did I
took my daughter down to the park you
know we went on the [ __ ] all the
rides and all that stuff just had like
the best time hanging out with her and
we said we'd watch the Bruins we watched
the Celtics why I watched the Bruins I
watched three Bruins games this [ __ ]
weekend the Panthers
Ottawa which both ended great and then
Pittsburgh got a feeling they were gonna
get us I mean we literally won like 18
or 19 in a row undefeated you know we
were like it we're like fifteen oh and
four I think so at some point someone
was gonna have to stop us and the
Penguins always play as tough and as
much as it sucked that the streak ended
it was our longest point streaks since I
guess the early 40s but I got to tell
you something Sydney Crosby's past in
the second period did anybody see that
Jesus Christ I mean oh yeah that's one
of those things you watch it's just like
what do we need robots for like that's
like the kind of thing like a robot you
know skating that fast trying to get
around a defenseman and then he has
another guy streaking down on the
outside of another two defenseman and
then you got the goalie who could poke
check the pass away he put it the only
place where it could [ __ ] be like a
top ray right on the tape bank bag in
the back of the [ __ ] net it was just
one of those it's one of those things
even though the other team did it you
can't even get mad you just like Jesus
Christ that was [ __ ] it was a thing of
beauty
so I don't have another [ __ ] gig other
than one quick benefit in New York that
I'm doing on April 2nd gardener dreams
msg in the theater where Eddie Murphy
did raw I always think about that when I
when I go down and do the show that this
is where he did that special and I saw
him on that tour that what used to be
called great woods in Mansfield
Massachusetts with the weather girls
opening up I for the life of me cannot
find any record of that date when it
happened I think I finally found it
when he one of you [ __ ] millennial
nerds find that all right it was like 85
or in 1986 Great Woods had just opened
Mansfield Massachusetts and that summer
I saw I saw Rodney Dangerfield and this
was post back to school he was that
movie hit and he was on this huge tour
and then I saw him and then that a
couple weeks later I saw Eddie Murphy
and I remember that that really was
something that stuck with me I was like
18 years old and I remember when I went
to see Dangerfield's watching him and
just looking around the crowd and it
didn't dawn on me that was an all-white
crowd because I you know I'm white as
just like this is what the world looks
like to me at that point in my life you
know
living in the safe suburbs of Boston
Massachusetts it was just a bunch of
white people so it didn't really dawn on
me that was an all-white crowd and I
member looking around thinking about man
this guy's making everybody laugh he's
killing this is amazing right and then a
couple weeks later I saw Eddie Murphy
and the crowd was mixed and I remember
that stuck with me I was like this kid
but this guy this guy's making everybody
laugh I had lawn seats for that I had
seats for Dangerfield so I actually saw
him and it kills me that I didn't try
and pony up some more money back then
but I didn't have any money to not sit
in the in a [ __ ] field I mean I
didn't really technically see him I was
just watching him on the monitors and
but he was wearing that purple mariachi
suit that he wore so anyways
[ __ ] am I talking about here how the
hell did I get onto that
I don't know and I watch the Celtics
versus the Lakers and at the risk of
sounding like an old man just I I
[ __ ] hate NBA hoop now you know it's
just it's he says [ __ ] up and down the
[ __ ] court everybody launching a three
there's nobody underneath you know the
other teams on a 1000 run yeah just keep
launching threes there's no feeding the
big man down low anymore nobody can
stand in the [ __ ] paint you know I
don't know I don't know what the [ __ ] is
going on with the Celtics I haven't
watched too much but I watched a bunch
the last couple years and I can tell you
this we had [ __ ] Jae Crowder and Kelly
Olynyk and everybody was [ __ ]
listening to Brad Stevens we were a
tougher team to beat we didn't have at
the level of talent but we were a
tougher team to beat and this whole
[ __ ] new era and you hear the
announcers just like you know they
condone the behavior that people get so
good that they don't have to listen to
the coach anymore and I'm not just
picking on the Celtics like that's like
around the [ __ ] league and I don't
know I know you know he's gonna have to
get his touches they're going out here
to win the [ __ ] game
drives me quick we have this
unbelievable chance right now with the
talent talent that we have we should be
able to at the very least scare the
Golden State Warriors I know we beat
them the other day in Regulus but that
doesn't mean [ __ ] it's one game regular
season like those guys are the [ __ ]
champs they're in the middle of a
[ __ ] dynasty and they're gonna have
an entirely different energy when you
meet them in the finals all right as
opposed to [ __ ] one game out of 80 or
whatever that you happen to catch them
on a [ __ ] Wednesday night and you
beat them we have this great opportunity
to win another one while the Lakers are
[ __ ] rebuilding and I love every
second panic mode like Magic Johnson -
those guys are doing exactly what the
[ __ ] they said they were gonna do we
brought in LeBron okay this is a
two-year plan like the fan
basis they're so [ __ ] impatient now
like a two-year plan it's taken too long
so it's literally you bring in [ __ ]
LeBron the first year and then he's
going to attract all of this free agent
help and then they're all gonna go out
there and pile on because everyone wants
to be part of the Lakers [ __ ] you
know great history and they want to [ __ ]
models and famous women you know that's
the [ __ ] over the Celtics they got the
weather and they got the [ __ ]
we just can't [ __ ] compete you know
you want to go race the city to race the
city we're right there we got your
eyeball to eyeball you want to go
championships we got two more than they
do unless you count that baa one that
they count but they have the weather and
they have the [ __ ] and that that right
[ __ ] there you know what I mean the
[ __ ] you gonna do with how do you beat
that location Location Location how many
titles do you think that the [ __ ]
Lakers would have had if they stayed in
Minneapolis okay and they had the exact
same ownership can they still attract
the level of talent that they attracted
being out there in Hollywood now all of
a sudden you're in the frozen tundra of
Minneapolis Minnesota right
you got [ __ ] farm fed chicks wearing
their overalls coming in from Duluth
right you got some hay seeds making the
trek in from [ __ ] the Dakotas I mean
I just don't see it I just don't I just
don't think there's enough [ __ ] and you
don't have the [ __ ] weather weather
in [ __ ]
have have caused more goddamn athletes
to make stupid [ __ ] moves to jump out
of the NFL and join the [ __ ] world
football league
well money to money whether and [ __ ]
the trifecta so I don't know I'm just
hoping people listen to Brad Stevens
just listen to what the [ __ ] this guy
says play like a goddamn team [ __ ] your
own stats and just go out there and get
it done and let's [ __ ] win another
one before the Lakers are coming cuz the
Lakers are coming they're always coming
ok it's almost like a rule they can only
suck for like five [ __ ] years before
they're gonna re and you know their
whole [ __ ] their whole [ __ ]
history is is free agents free agents
ready right down to Kobe Bryant it was a
[ __ ] Charlotte Hornet and what kills
me you know look at that Antonio Brown
like yeah you're going to the Bills yeah
I'm not playing for them okay like I
don't understand the bills just made a
move to get one of the top receivers in
the league but he doesn't like where the
[ __ ] they are so he's not gonna [ __ ]
go I mean that day I don't know what
happened to parity in the [ __ ] league
I'd like listen I'm all for like players
not getting [ __ ] over by ownership but
they're at the point now where they have
too much power you know kind of like
where the unions were when I was a kid
which caused all these [ __ ]
corporations to be like alright well
we're just gonna move the corporation
out of this [ __ ] country then go back
to sweatshop labor you know then I don't
I don't mind you in unions I'm not
saying don't have a [ __ ] union but
whose kid nope you know most people
don't handle power well right they
became too greedy to kunti too much
leaning on the mop and then the [ __ ]
rich guys were like yeah we're [ __ ]
out of here I got to tell you something
all of what I've just said here I don't
think I've ever really read on it I just
this is all me just pasting together
conversations I've heard throughout my
life okay like I've said before if you
want clear and accurate information you
listen to the Joe Rogan podcast by the
way I have to get that guy a shout-out
right as far as like that what that guy
has done with his part have you
looking at the [ __ ] guests at that
guy's getting he's gay like Elon Musk
and the dr. Phil and the David Lee Roth
and then like some scientists that ever
even heard of who then blows my mind
about like some sort of like I don't
know I know some scientific [ __ ] I know
[ __ ] night I mean I'm too stupid
understand it but like that guy is like
I don't know I don't know what's cool
aware this podcasting world goes but
like at this point if you do if you're a
guest on his show you get more heat than
if you do like like a [ __ ] legendary
talk show it's honor it's unbelievable
what that guy is is has done I was just
thinking the other day I think what the
[ __ ] yes did I see I think once it David
Lee Roth I think it was just the the
variety of guests they getting dr. Phil
that's [ __ ] huge I mean that is like
a big mainstream old-school guest I'm
gonna go do the talk show circuit I'm
gonna [ __ ] go do terrestrial radio
and all that you get that [ __ ] guy me
that I thought that that was a big you
know I don't know that's a big moment
that's that's right up there
you know when Maron had Obama on I think
when they look back yet like what are
these podcasts come from and what was
some of the watershed moments like I
would say I don't know stamps.com
starting to advertise and then it goes
Obama on Marc Maron's and then it's Joe
Rogan's numbers and his wide variety of
get I mean he had like Elon Musk on his
show the guy took a head of a joint and
it affected his stock prices that's
[ __ ] amazing anyways but meanwhile
here I sit and my [ __ ] sweat pants
talking to myself
stubborn stubborn German Irish guy just
gonna do it this way I don't want to
talk to people man not [ __ ] with you
if you've noticed when I do interviews
I'm a lot of times are too busy thinking
about what the [ __ ] I want to say or
somebody says something and I drift off
and then it becomes like that Chris
Farley thing where I'm just [ __ ]
grabbing the side of my pants going then
when you did this that was awesome
all right so Oh Billy no booze bag okay
a hundred and seven [ __ ] days and I
went to the gym yesterday and for the
first time in like three years
I did a dip testing out my shoulders
fortunately where I go to the gym they
have like this the the dip machine you
can actually remove the dip bar and
adjust it to your height so I have it
just way down near the floor where my
arms are actually straight when I'm
holding on to it and then I just sort of
went up on my toes you know supporting
my weight with my arms and went up on my
toes like Michael Jackson you don't and
you know - that documentary or whatever
the [ __ ] is going on with that and I was
just loaned myself down and every day
every time I felt a little bit stronger
and then yesterday I was like I think I
can do one I did one felt all right and
then I kind of did three in a row and I
was just like why did I just do that
because I'm finding what the the rotator
cuff it's uh is it rotator or wrote
rotor cuff rotator cuff rotor cuff Jesus
Christ II me I've had this injury for
three [ __ ] years and I don't it's one
you know I just had these words that I
don't really know how to say so I just
say them fast some oh people don't
notice rotator cuff
yeah oh and first I use think is it
rotator cup a rotator cuff I know what
the [ __ ] it is if you're still listening
god bless you that's all I can say so
anyways I was able to do that and then
they have one of those those those pull
up machines that you can you know be on
your knees with like the weight and all
that stuff so I did like two or three of
those and now it's [ __ ] hilarious is
I'm kind of feeling a weird feeling in
my other shoulder because
I think this one got worn out because of
the other one and I think I'm finally
I'm just gonna go get an MRI on both of
my shoulders figure out what the [ __ ]
going on and then I might do a Rogen but
Rogen's been telling me to do is go
[ __ ] check out this guy that does the
stem cell thing and they just shoot it
in there and all of a sudden you're like
a [ __ ] x-men I think I might do that
you know I think I deserve that I did I
didn't get the hair plugs right I'm not
doing Botox I'm aging naturally you know
I don't think is anything wrong with
rebuilding the engine and my [ __ ]
shoulders now jeez my kids screaming
down there but anyways I haven't been
drinking I haven't really been smoking
and I don't know I'm actually calling a
[ __ ] therapist today to fajn because
I've been saying on my on stage I've
been working on my anger but I've been
kind of doing it on my own and I'm
finally gonna get some help here and
I've been doing this joke at my axe
saying like you know if I just didn't
have a temper like as far as like you
know your wife's always you know trying
to we'll say in a nice way try it's
always trying to help you become a
better person like I think if I got rid
of my temper she would be out of
suggestions you know because other than
my temper I mean I'm [ __ ] crushing it
do you understand that guys do you
understand that I am a man that can
still afford to pay for DirecTV 900
channels 350 of which are radio stations
I don't even listen to those you know
I'll [ __ ] I'll pay for that Direct TV
subscription and then I'll order a UFC
fight and a sports package
I don't give a [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] off
I'll [ __ ] stare right at $300 bill
pay it just like that
I'm sorry I'm doing this I just was so
shamed for still paying for [ __ ]
cable I didn't I didn't I didn't know
that yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] doing this
[ __ ] where I got everything's like I
like it all right there on my [ __ ] TV
like watch this on my laptop I watched
this on my phone I got this thing on
Mike Mike [ __ ] pad bill they're all
the same technology you can watch them
anywhere I I don't want to figure I
don't want to figure it out [ __ ]
channels boo boo doo doo doo doo doo
all right you knew all the [ __ ] songs
making the way in your world today who
can smile who can take her hairy muff
and warm some [ __ ] up there Ben
Minneapolis well the [ __ ] Lakers Mary
Tyler Moore's [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry um all
right let's read some let's read some
advertising all right oh look who's back
everybody but at data all zip you know
hiring is a challenge but there's one
place you can go where hiring is simple
sometimes you wanna go where hiring
people is [ __ ] soon boom boom boom
boom boom and it's [ __ ] fast and
smart
boom boo boo you want to keep on [ __ ]
boozing without anybody giving your [ __ ]
you want to hang with more alcohol licks
yep sorry
a place where growing business is
connected to qualified candidates that
place is zip dot-com / / zip Krita sends
your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards they know it's not
that with their powerful matching
technology exhibit a relevance
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip analyzes each
one and spots light spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zipper cruda is so effective that
80% of employees who post on say get a
quality that's my mind nod to motorcycle
racing get a quality candidate through
the site within the first day and right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free yet this exclusive web address
zip recruited dot-com / / that zip
recruited comm / / spell it out zi p re
crui ter dot-com / burp simple crota
this modest way to hire all right look
it I I talked about him earlier in here
they are stamps.com everybody sliding in
like Kramer on Seinfeld no one really
has time to go to the post office you're
busy who's got you got to be a busy
looking at all watching you give your
apps you know check out [ __ ] TV oh are
you watching who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging all your mail
and packages let's get lugging mail I
mean Jesus Christ how many [ __ ]
envelopes do you have it's a pain in the
ass we get it it's a real hassle man
that's why you need stamps calm one of
the most popular time-saving tools for
small businesses business
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and saves you money with
discounts that you can get even at the
post office
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
seller shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease simply use your computer to print
you official US postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it over to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox mail
carrier you got that you see that that
was that was unisex not mailman nut mail
woman mail carrier person carrier why
does it say mail it's that simple with
stamps.com you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of those expensive
postage meters stamps comb is a
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm not
to mention it's a fraction of the cost I
just wanted right back hey I just was
checking the time to see where I was at
sorry I'm not losing my money here right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus put
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and try and type
in burpee you are our that stamps comm
enter ber be you are are okay there we
go that was that was relatively painless
right you know I realized halfway
through this I need to let somebody know
that I'm not gonna be able to get to
where the [ __ ] I'm supposed to be but
anyways we plow forward here okay creepy
Lennon mannequin alright a couple weeks
ago I was in Liverpool and I went down
to this this oh it says right here
magical Beatles Museum okay this I
actually and I was making fun of that
[ __ ] John Lennon statue if you missed
the episode it you cuz if literally that
one of the first [ __ ] things you see
and it's like the white suit like I'll
[ __ ] is that the white suit why would
that be out here in the open where
anybody could just take it you walk up
you realize it isn't the white suit you
realize it doesn't look like [ __ ]
John Lennon at all it's got this awful
beard like taped to the things face I
mean it just it just looks like a ripoff
I mean they might as well I had a
[ __ ] two-headed goat standing out
there or something so I made fun of it
so anyways it says hi Bill I work at the
magical Beatles Museum and parentheses I
like most of the staff agree with you
the mannequin
should be thrown in the river merci
merci okay
the guys from cheap trick found it weird
as well alright so that's a major
[ __ ] bandwidth I believe that bands
in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and
they are looking at it like dude what
the [ __ ] it's unfortunate you and your
pal decided not to come in as the
mannequin certainly does not represent
what is inside the museum is on three
floors and is filled with 300 and
Counting genuine Beatles artifacts from
1959 to 1970s as making me wish I went
in there you gotta get rid of that
[ __ ] mannequin these include the
medals John Lennon wore on the Sergeant
Pepper cover Wow George Harrison's
future Rama guitar I know what that is
the spotlights from Abbey Road Studios
Ringo Starr's snare drum Jesus seats
from Shea Stadium and the cello from the
Blue Jay way video etc etc etc the owner
of the museum also the guy responsible
for the creepy mannequin is rogue Aspen
Ollie best I didn't couldn't tell if
that was an affliction or a nail it's a
name okay he's the son of Neil Aspen
Ally Beatles roadie and head of Apple
records he's also brother of Pete best
original Beatles drummer and is a great
guy next time you were in Liverpool come
in and we'll give you and your pals
slash family a free tour all the best
bill [ __ ] that dude I'm gonna pay I'm
gonna pay although I would ask him it
does Pete get upset that he started a
[ __ ] museum to the band that fired
him fired his brother it's got to be
kind of weird right um I don't know I'm
sure I'm sure Pete best is over it at
this point right I vote is there any
other you know that's another thing to
you know on Twitter I'm an old man I'm
still on Twitter right I'm still on the
Twitter somebody had this this hashtag
going around that said not popular
opinions and people would say like you
know I don't know pick somebody like I
don't think Adele has a good voice you
know stupid [ __ ] like nobody said that
by the way I'm just happy I know how to
say her name I was calling her a delay
for a long [ __ ] time
but somebody wrote the Beatles are
overrated that's another one that's a
big one
when Millennials want to appear edgy
they go they're overrated
oh are they okay okay well maybe if you
read up on the history at some [ __ ]
point Jesus I get a phone call hang on a
second all right here's the thing about
that I understand if the Beatles you're
young and the Beatles music doesn't move
you because I mean it's music from
literally 50 [ __ ] years ago at this
point that's the end of their career too
and then the other stuff is coming up on
60 years okay so in defense you guys I
understand that if you don't like it or
it does but they're not overrated I mean
they just they influenced an entire
generation of bands to get started they
made the whole [ __ ] thing possible
and because of them you're listening to
the music that you're listening to today
they are an undeniable part of music
history but I would never you know be
this old guy going like you know if you
told me that music sucks I'm not gonna
argue that that's just like I mean if I
[ __ ] grew up now I would like some of
their songs even I remember in the 80s
like liking them and my teacher being
like going like dude you don't get it
you don't get how [ __ ] huge it was
when a Beatles album came out it's like
the thought the [ __ ] world stopped
for younger people then and you bought
it and people I'll do it I got the new
Beatles album everybody came over and
[ __ ] listened to it I mean I wasn't
even part of that so but as far as like
like Fergie always suffers he hates the
Beatles and he's just like Yellow
Submarine bill yellow sub-sect dude
everybody's got a bad [ __ ] joke in
there Rach come on anyways you know
first yeah you know whatever I it's I
get it I get it it's it's too much time
has passed
I've heard I've heard younger comics
talk about some big comics that way and
not get like what the big deal is but
what happens is is the further like look
look at Beethoven can you [ __ ]
imagine when that [ __ ] first came out
like it just kept [ __ ] sitting there
you got a goddamn boil the size of my
foot on the side of your [ __ ] head
you fighting off typhoid yellow feet
whatever the [ __ ] goddamn plague and
also this guy just shows up with the
hunter of his friends I like what the
[ __ ] you know and now you just sitting
there eating a Subway sandwich in an
elevator and in the backgrounds gone but
it uh but it just it does something have
the same [ __ ] impact but that it
doesn't mean the dudes overrated does it
I don't [ __ ] know anyways when I had
here or if you look at you people get
what is it the salt you've watched Soul
Train if you watch some of the people
dancing from way [ __ ] back then
there's a lot of them that I've compared
to today's standards I'm not talking
about the legendary dancers just people
on the dance floor I just when I watch
because Nia loves that show and I'll be
just watching I just laugh going like
you know there's a lot of people on this
show that are dancing at a level that
awful white people dance at today like
the bar just keeps getting raised off of
the work so if you go back the hardest
thing to do when you go back in history
is to block out what has happened since
then and try to put it into historical
perspective which is practically
impossible it's like going back and
looking at Johnny Unitas how he threw
for over forty thousand yards in his
career and like the next closest guy had
half as much as that but now I like the
way the rules have chains like a [ __ ]
goddamn backup quarterback will throw
for thirty thousand in his career so it
doesn't seem like a big deal so I don't
know I'm just defending the Beatles
that's all
and I feel bad that I trashed his
[ __ ] Museum and I judged it by that
goddamn mannequin I think the whole
purpose all that was me just realizing
that I'm a bit of a [ __ ]
he's a bit of a [ __ ] there he is he's a
bit of a [ __ ]
all right cheesy cheesing babies dear
Billy badge have you seen these [ __ ]
throwing cheese onto their kids faces I
saw one of them it's just the [ __ ]
desperation for people to get views on
the Internet to the appointment look I'm
a performer I have a desperation for it
I get it on some level but when you
start like the amount of videos I just
see of like parents with like their kids
right and they're starting to fall and
they don't do anything and they just
film it so they can laugh and they just
like let their kid get hurt is you know
the real ones like you can tell it
wasn't set up is because right as a kid
starts to fall like that you see the
[ __ ] phone flies out of frame and you
actually missed the kid falling down if
she can tell the parent lunged and tried
to save the person but yeah I don't get
it anyone's like how much the person
said how much do you hate yourself that
you'd throw cheese on a baby's face just
imagine what type of memory is sublimely
stored where a baby sees a camera and
then something hit their face I'd arrest
all these [ __ ] parents and throw fire
hose water in it at their faces yeah I
mean I don't know if it does like
psychological damage to the baby if you
can even [ __ ] remember it like some
day it's gonna be in Philly and they lay
hey you want to get a cheesesteak it's
like a [ __ ] it starts slamming the
sandwich into its face I don't know that
it does that if there is just the thing
where when you are you become a parent
just sound like defenseless and helpless
your kid is look I'm not advocating
being a helicopter parent I'm not saying
that but there's just something about
filming it like
because it's the kid obviously doesn't
enjoy it obviously startles the kid and
the fact that you're putting your own
[ __ ] adult needs ahead of that I mean
all of that that whole category is
giving you kid a stupid [ __ ] name
like coat hanger or some dumb Hollywood
celebrity [ __ ] name or putting your
[ __ ] political agenda like your kid
is gonna live your political agenda I'm
raising my kid gender-neutral and then
all of a sudden your kid asks your son
has to wear a [ __ ] dress just so you
can show off how [ __ ] progress if you
are rather than asking the kid if he
just wants a football instead you know
what I mean like you're gonna make that
decision I think all of that stuff is I
don't know what though I'm not a
psychologist I just it's not how I would
do it you know I think you should if
your kid starts to fall you should try
to catch your kid I think if there's
cheese you should hand it to your child
if your kid wants to eat it they eat it
if they don't then you finish it and
gain a few more pounds like a dad right
I don't know and I also just like if
your kid [ __ ] up and then you put it
on the internet it's just like it exists
forever and kids are already mean you're
literally giving like ammunition like
somebody showed me this video this woman
her kid was being a class clown and
dancing at school and she gave him the
option she says I'm either gonna give
you the belt or you can dance so the kid
is crying because he's scared and he's
sitting there doing this half-assed like
dance and while he's crying and
everybody thinks it's funny it's like
this [ __ ] kid has to go to school not
to mention you should hit a kid with a
belt there's like so many [ __ ] things
that are wrong with it
I don't know so yeah I don't I don't
like and I think you know your instincts
that you're that mad that you you that
could feel the anger that you have
towards it yeah like you shouldn't do
that I imagine with your level of anger
like some [ __ ] was done to you
as was done to me and I think you go one
of two ways you either repeated slash
trying to take it to the next level or
you just go back to like I remember what
that felt like I yeah I'm not doing that
why would I do that but you know there's
a lot of morons that you know you don't
have to be smart to know how to [ __ ]
that's the thing if they just made it
like something like like if it was as
difficult as getting like a degree in
something I think the world would be a
better place but anybody can be like
good but dick stared it up but I wanted
to stick it in there next thing you know
you have a [ __ ] kid and you're
throwing cheese at it and you're filming
it I don't know I it's I wouldn't do it
we'll see we'll see what the fallout is
but my kids not going to be part of that
[ __ ] experiment all right Premiere
League soccer soccer is in quotes so I'm
imagining this is a [ __ ] somebody who
doesn't live in the u.s. hey Billy
ballbreaker I've been listening for a
long time and really enjoy your podcasts
especially during football season as I
find your analysis is put more in
layman's terms for us Brits being a
fellow Patriot fan nice hear also gets
me [ __ ] as most people follow the
Seahawks well isn't that interesting if
you don't mind write back and let me
know why did they follow the Seahawks
it's because it's always cloudy over
there and they have the same kind of
weather in Britain as they do in Seattle
that's really interesting I've enjoyed
your recent ramblings about the Premier
League in Liverpool's battle with
Manchester this year so I thought I'd
share a few facts you may enjoy and help
you understand more Liverpool were
actually the more successful team in
history with 18 League titles oh yeah I
heard about this this is like before the
Premier League existed it's almost like
pre Super Bowl era they had five Europe
okay so 18 League titles five European
titles and a bunch of other cups until
recently when their biggest rivals
Manchester United overtook them and have
twenty titles but only three European
titles so that's basically the Celtics
and Lakers
of Premier League football given your
gripe about the Steelers I thought you'd
be interested to know that all 18 of
Liverpool's titles were before the
Premier League era but are still very
much counted here as it should be yes it
should their Wikipedia page is very
interesting as they have also faced
tragedies along with other clubs and
still cake out on top never heard that
expression unless you that's a typo
secondly Man Man City are only recently
a good team as ten years ago they were
about they were I think he missed a word
here as ten years ago they were about
over by era but I think they were bought
out is what he wanted Arab billionaires
and have basically played paid
extraordinary amounts of money for the
best players and are still not quite
good enough to win all the cups see this
is this is what you need to get into it
it's already a beautiful game and now I
need is the backstory and the drama so I
think that's really interesting that Man
City all of a sudden they have all this
money which who gives a [ __ ] cuz you
know before then everyone was probably
going to man united or Liverpool's they
wanted to win a title now hey they come
out of nowhere I like it it's good you
know you guys all got money the Boston
Red Sox on the Liverpool god knows they
got [ __ ] more money than God
what about Man United do they got a
bunch of money with that legacy I feel
like they need to do something soon or
all of a sudden it starts to fade a
little bit like the Michigan Wolverines
like thank God they got a
what's-his-face there captain come back
to save that and he did even though he
hasn't beat no house they yet Harbaugh
saved that [ __ ] program because you
can only be bad for so long we're all
this if you suck for a kid's in a
recruit's entire life they don't give a
[ __ ]
that becomes beetle every stuff like
yeah whatever that's Yellow Submarine
football I don't give a [ __ ] about it
and they're going to end up like Oregon
came out of nowhere cuz all of a sudden
they started having these cool uniforms
and started winning games
don't a total tangent here so let's ear
we go thirdly going on what you said
about the offsides rule and the
defending player slowing down they can
do this but if the attacking player is
behind them when the ball is played they
are still on side and can score wait how
does that work the attacking player is
behind them when the ball is played well
doesn't I mean he ran past him with the
ball he can't go past the last defender
without the ball right so the attacker
must time their run with the there are
other players making the pass and the
defending players must do the same but
also be aware that if they get oh I see
what you're saying so like if he's like
parallel to or is it perpendicular if
he's parallel to the defenseman and
somebody kicks the ball past the
defenseman he can take off as the balls
kicked and then he won't heal he'll
still be on side I get that all right
that's a little more okay I guess so
it's sort of like a moving blue line I
guess I really appreciate you taking the
time to explain this to me though so let
me read that again slowly when the ball
is played that means kicked I guess then
they are still on the outside and could
score so the Atelier where the [ __ ] was
third they going on what you said about
the offsides rule and the defending
players slowing down they can do this
but if the attacking player is behind
them when the ball is played meaning
kicked then they are still on side and
can score so the attacker must time
their run with their other player I like
that there's a finesse to that I have to
respect making the pass well do you have
to respect it you [ __ ] arrogant [ __ ]
yeah whatever I'm trying to be nicer and
the defending players must do the same
but also be aware that if they get if
they get wrong they have to chase back
and stop the goal there are also other
factors such as the other player isn't
involved in the play he isn't offside
can stand anywhere alright apologies for
the length nah man you actually cleared
it up a little bit more I still don't
think i 100% understand it because I
don't know how far away you have to be
from the play and you can still be on
side I hope you found this interesting
and please do a show and either Belfast
or Dublin so I can go thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself I was out in Dublin last June
I haven't been to Belfast in a little
bit but I have to tell you how excited
the two tours I've done this year
through Europe it's been incredible and
I got one more that starts in Iceland at
the end of April and it's I don't know
it's just incredible the people showing
up the venue's I get to play - yeah I
don't know I'm still kind of blown away
by that so I'm looking forward to it and
I still AM have not been down to
Australia I keep saying every something
always ends up coming up I got some
acting work I had to push some dates but
after I do my next Europe run the next
one I do I have to go back to Australia
because I haven't been there in a couple
of years alright and now I just take the
special sand I got to build the [ __ ]
our back up again and I can't go over
there when it's weak I got to make sure
you know cuz those Aussies [ __ ]
people don't screw around alright so I
gotta make sure it's where it needs to
be but I will figure all of this out
alright alright binaural beats bi nua
RAL beats deer bill have you heard of
binary aisle beats they are a great
alternative to silent meditation and
have the same benefits all you need is a
nice pair of headphones and YouTube on
your phone just wanted to let you know
because I'm also an angry [ __ ] sometimes
I found these and they really help with
every negative emotion they are even a
few there are even a few that apparently
help with migraines check them out
thanks for the laugh is this a real
thing is this a thing
see here we go let me right let me let
me let me look this up here B I nu a RAL
for the people looking it up two beats
all right all right this is from
meditation this is three hours and 15
minutes let's a little little listen to
a little bit of this vegetarians LV Lily
eat french fries don't they here we go
here is some fine URI old beats
something a horror movie
[Music]
you
all right you know I can get it to that
start off a little scary start it off
alumni gonna lie to you I was a little
Lily
oh speaking of scary movies if you if
you see Jordan peels the trailer for his
new movie that movie looks so scary I'm
almost angry at him cuz I'm gonna go see
it I saw that and he was like oh my god
I was like - [ __ ] that movie [ __ ] I'm
gonna go see it but Jesus Christ oh my
god I I [ __ ] hate scary movies but I
love Jordan so I'm gonna go see that
movie and I also love this is the last
one he did so but like this one looks
like it's just full-on [ __ ] horror
and I don't need that but you know I'm
gonna go see it
alright boyfriend's family is silent
during dinner
we should go see at me and E and then
we'll come on the podcast and talk about
it she's like oh my god I loved that I
loved being scared and I'll be [ __ ]
pissed that I went through that [ __ ] you
know I told you when I saw it when I saw
the Blair Witch I had a set at the Laugh
Factory and I went to the move like the
midnight showing by myself and then I
walked out into the parking garage by
myself to the car just totally freaked
off like Josh like I don't I'm not one
of those people that can just sit there
and be like this is the movie I [ __ ]
buy in and it scares the [ __ ] out of me
alright boyfriend's family is silent
during dinner okay let's see what do we
do with this one dear bill I need some
advice about a guy I've been seeing who
is great but his family are kind of
strange they are lovely and quite nice
but they are incredibly awkward when
together as a family it's not that they
say or do weird things it's that we
basically sit in silence word together
when I first met him when I first met
them Jesus Christ I feel like I should
be playing that meditation music well I
[ __ ] worry as I read this there's
nobody there stirring coffee slowly are
they or tea whatever it was when I first
met them I thought that they must have
just came from a funeral because we went
out for lunch and it was eerily silent
I was trying to be nice and ask a few
question but I was just getting one-word
answers I asked my boyfriend about this
and he had no idea what I was talking
about he even started to get a bit
defensive oh all right well there you go
that's that's just how they are
he said we've been dating about six
months and I dread seeing them because
it feels like I'm being tortured in an
under threat of speaking
my boyfriend is completely oblivious to
it and loved seeing his family which is
crazy weird because I would say he is
reasonably outgoing and fun when we go
out with a group of friends yeah that is
what's really [ __ ] weird should I
stop seeing him or do you think he
missed a word you think would be some
good techniques for dealing with them
please give me some advice hey you're
single you're not married so this is all
about you all right you you just have to
you have to figure out do I love this
guy you haven't even said you loved him
am i into this person enough to put up
with this like these people you have a
kid with this guy these [ __ ]
non-talking [ __ ] are coming
over to your house alright it seems like
you're early on what you like should I
stop seeing this guy or should maybe it
all depends on how much you like the guy
[Music]
that's so it's so weird that there it's
not weird that they're like that and
it's not weird that he's oblivious cuz
you know your family just seems like
your family you grew up but the fact
that he loves seeing them that's what's
weird to me like if they just like a not
close cold family that barely talks like
that's usually would mean that you know
I seen once every year year and a half I
come around during the holidays and then
that's it but the fact that he goes
there all the time to sit there and then
not say anything to them I don't know it
starts making me wonder if they're like
[ __ ] Hey
Lien's or something they're
communicating through the center of
their foreheads or some [ __ ] yeah that's
definitely strange and the fact that
you're so uncomfortable that now you're
thinking maybe there's some good
techniques that you're going to go in
there and dr. Phil and fix the whole
[ __ ] family in one segment it's not
going to happen so I think you need to
you got to make a tough choice there all
right
neither let this great guy go and try to
find another great guy you sound like
you're still young still drafting in the
first couple of rounds so there's plenty
of good talent left out there and maybe
you could have more of a normal family
but that is or you just learned to deal
with their creepy Horror Show
[ __ ] vibe but I don't know what good
techniques you're going to use to fix
that
especially when you brought it up to him
he had no idea what you were talking
about and was like defensive about it so
so there is that anyways I'm gonna try
that that [ __ ] horror music chanting
[ __ ] sorry you you're all I was I think
I would actually like this better than I
have a meditation app and it's just this
and this guy just keeps talking
throughout being like hello again and
welcome to another beautiful day with an
opportunity to clear your mind meditate
you to find a comfortable chair and just
sit in it feel the chair up against your
body are there places that it's touching
you too much or does it feel just right
it's [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's just like oh
my god dude just shut the [ __ ] up all
right just tell me to breathe and then
just shut up please for the love of God
shut up so I think I would rather rather
than listen that guy I'd rather listen
to this [ __ ] alright I don't mean end
this so [ __ ] in such a creepy goddamn
way maybe I need a list of this [ __ ] so
I can go see Jordan peels new [ __ ]
movie and not be overly freaked out and
traumatized by it how great is it that
that guy's making movies is it every
once in a while somebody [ __ ] like
that comes along it's just awesome it's
awesome if you love movies it's [ __ ]
awesome alright that is the that is the
podcast ladies and gentlemen I'll check
it on ya on Thursday go Bruins go
Celtics if anybody knows how if I can
watch a replay of the MotoGP race I
would love to watch it send it to my
Twitter account please let me know I
would love to see it alright that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll see you on
Thursday